Sứng dành ai ngộ lợi của hồ, tiêu tá quân đời ở Việt ăn giống thẳng tầm của cho bẻ giữa giống lú giữ.
Bà chương ngày hai mới tư tăng chính, tiêu tá quân nhanh chuyên nghiệp hô sĩ trang, khuê quân lưu,
về ăn khi đang chuyên đường từ đơn vị về nhà thì phát hiện trong những tiệt chật,
sinh năm hai ngàn không chăm mùi tám đặc xe qua đập tràn ở giác quyền châu, quyền lưu, cặc nước tướng trả xét,
hình có chơi cả người và xe. Không chân chữ xe phút nào, tiêu tá chang đặc bây ra giữa giống lúc lúc lưu cho vào bữa ăn tòn.
Được biết, chói nhật là học sinh chương tự học quyền cho bê,
bố mẹ chảo đi làm ăn xa, nên cháo ở vị ông, mặt nội,
thưa diền sảy ra sự việc trên, chói đang trên đường đi học bê.
Sức thẩm ở việc làm giúp cảng của thư tá chang,
hành động của ăn đã tồ thẩm tiêm phẩm chất tất đẹp mộn yーデe của hồ trong lòng, gynh dân.